hello everyone I guess the next row goes
about explaining landscape connectivity
of low-cost solutions for multi-layer
networks okay thanks for coming and
thanks for inviting me today I'm going
to talk about this very interesting
phenomena of landscape connectivity so
this is joint work with many people
mostly because I got really excited
about the project and I told many people
about it so it's with rohith's and young
from Duke and Houghton eg one way and
San Shi from Princeton okay so so first
what is this landscape connectivity
property that I'm talking about well
this is a phenomena also known as mode
connectivity that has been discovered in
many recent papers so roughly speaking
this is the property of some neural
network solutions so for neural networks
local minima that are found by doing
gradient descent or other popular
optimization algorithms are actually
found to be connected by simple pass in
the parameter space by connected by
simple pass I mean it's a property of
the past is that every point on the pass
is another solution where another
parameter of neural networks that have
almost the same cost as two endpoints so
here
this is a picture representing this
phenomena this comes from one of the
papers by agrabuff at all so so here we
have solutions a and B so think of these
as two
minimizer's said you find by randomly
initializing the neural network at two
independent be random locations and you
run gradient descent where SGD and you
find these two solutions a and B they
both have a lower cost so in this figure
the warmer colors are represent lower
cost and the coder colors represent high
cost as you can see if I look at just
these two solutions a and B and if I try
to do a direct interpolation between a
and B
then it actually goes through an energy
barrier right in the middle of this line
the cost is actually very high on the
other hand that actually is not true for
every pass that's connecting a and B in
particular in this paper they are able
to find this pass by introducing this
additional point C in in between and if
you look at it's a path from A to C and
then from C to B then the in her path
lies in this red region and and the red
region is the region with the lowest
cost right so these paths can be so
simple that it's just two line segments
were in the papers they also use other
simple curves like a basal curve so you
can you can find these paths fairly
consistently for many architectures of
neural networks and that's very
surprising phenomena when I first
learned about it so in this talk I'm
first going to explain why I was
actually super surprised when I learned
about this and maybe why you should also
be a little bit surprised and then I
will talk about our results which shows
a local minimum a certain type of local
minima are actually connected by paths
and towards the end I will talk about
what what does this mean right how can
we use this property as an open problem
okay so as a background I was really
surprised by this result because I was
working on these non convex optimization
and optimization landscape so in the
past few years me and many collaborators
and many other researchers were able to
prove that many non convex objectives
satisfy what I will call the locally
optimizable property so what is this
property for these functions all local
minima are actually globally optimal as
in this function as you can see they are
two equivalent local and global optimal
solutions and these objectives also
don't have any high order saddle points
and because of these are a lot of
algorithms including gradient descent
but there are many other algorithms
can be guaranteed to find a local
minimum very efficient before these
functions and because of the first
property that is also a global optimal
solution so that kind of explains why
local search algorithms can optimize
some of the non convex functions so when
we are doing these kind of work the
objective functions that we and many
other researchers were able to prove
mostly fall into two categories
I would say so one category are what I
will call the matrix problems so these
are problems like matrix sensing matrix
every problem where you are trying to
find a low rank matrix okay there are
many ways can solve the problem but in
the non convex approach if you want to
find a low rank matrix you will actually
it's the right this low rank matrix M as
a product of two smaller matrices so
this guarantees the rank is well here
I'm of course looking at the simpler
case where m is also a symmetric PSD but
there are also results for more general
a symmetric matrices so an important
property of this type of problem is we
only care about the final matrix M I
don't actually care about these factors
X so as long as I get a factor X that
gives me the same low rank matrix M I'm
actually very happy so this is kind of a
symmetry within the non convex objective
and this gives a lot of equivalent
solutions so if X star is an optimal
solution then I can write multiply x
star with an matrix R r is a orthonormal
matrix so if I do that then xx transpose
will not change and that's why all of
these solutions are equivalent as they
gives the same matrix in contrast to the
matrix problems there's another class of
problems that I'm going to call tensor
problems but these are not all tensor
decomposition problems these are all the
problems where you are trying to find K
different components so these can be K
components in the tensor decomposition
where those who are not familiar with
tensor decomposition you can also think
of these as say k centers of clusterings
or k neurons in a two layer neural
network so it's just you are trying to
find K vectors that are different okay
and in in these kind of problems it
doesn't really matter what I call a
which one I call the first vector which
one I call the second vector which one I
call the third vector as long as the
setup vectors it's the same the solution
is okay so because of that symmetry we
again have many equivalent solutions so
here if X star is an optimal solution so
think of the columns of X star as the
vector said we are looking for then I
can write multiply X star with a
permutation matrix so that basically
gives the same set of column vectors and
that is the same solution so the reason
why these two problems are very
different is because they have very
different symmetry right and because of
these symmetries I have always had
intuition that the matrix problems they
will have mostly connected local minimum
right because the set of orthonormal
matrices is mostly connected I say
mostly because it does have two
connected component one with determinant
one one with minus one so that's why I
think the picture is going to look like
that for matrix problems for the tensor
problems because permutations are very
discrete objects so I always have the
idea that for these tensor problems were
including actually neural networks will
have isolated local minimum so this
picture looks quite different from the
connected local minimum that we actually
saw were for neural networks in practice
right so that's why I was super
surprised when I learned that neural
network solutions are actually connected
the reason is neural networks
I thought only half permutation symmetry
so why do they actually have connected
local minimum right well there's a short
but partial answer to that
the answer has been this has been an
answer to many problems that have been
mentioned in this workshop right so the
partial short answer is because of our
parameterization right we are not trying
to train a neural network with exactly
the smallest number of neurons that's
possible yeah in practice we probably
over promote rides by trying to learn a
neural network with many more neurons
and because of that the landscape is
going to change significantly indeed
this was a explanation of this mod
connectivity phenomena in many of the
existing works so a short summary of
these work is that if the network has
special structure so it's easier to
layer or it's multi-layer but has some
special structures and if the network is
very or parametrize by or very / apart
parametrize I mean the number of neurons
is larger than the number of training
samples you don't think I show all the
local minimum are actually connected so
of course this our very our parametrize
regime is kind of similar to the ndk
regime that has been mentioned in this
workshop it's actually slightly better
in the sense that you just need number
of neurons to be bigger than the number
of training examples you don't need a
polynomial factor there but still is
arguably it's arguable whether this
whether the neural networks that we
actually use are very or primate right
it's always the case it's a number of
parameters is much larger than the
number of training samples work very
often the case but it's very often not
the case that the number of neurons is
actually larger than the number of
training samples and especially when you
actually consider a convolutional neural
networks some of these results requires
a number of channels to be larger than
the training samples and that's
definitely not true okay so bottom line
is all of these analysis are very nice
but in practice networks are not as /
parametrized as these theories require
but you
and though the networks are not as a
workaround tries in practice people were
still able to find these paths that are
connecting different local minima so
that's why I'm saying this is just a
partial answer and in our interview we
give another partial answer of course
I'm not going to claim that even taking
the union of these two partial answers
are going to explain entirely the mode
connectivity phenomena but we give
another regime where this can be proved
okay so what we prove so we first
actually give a lower bound that says
for neural networks not all local or
global minima are connected even in the
or parent right setting okay so this
might sound contradicting to the
existing result our question general
property of neural networks right so so
the question is whether mode
connectivity has been demonstrated for
random data so we haven't done the
experiment on the other hand so it's a
previous result that requires a very
over Prem try setting so those proofs
are actually do not depend anything on
the data distribution so in those three
dreams no matter what you are data is
including random data you will have more
connective the practical regimes we we
haven't tried so so I don't know it's
possible that it may not work well our
theories definitely suggest that it
would not work when you have random
things but but we haven't tried that
okay so yeah so first we actually talk
about even in the over cram try setting
not all our men are connected well this
might sound that it's contradicting this
previous result I will explain why they
are not and since not all local minima
are connected we think we actually focus
on a special type of solutions in
particular we show that solutions that
satisfy what we are going to define as
drop off stability are actually
connected by simple paths and we can
also switch dropout connect stability
with some other notions of stability
such as noise stability that were used
before for proving generalization bounds
for neural networks okay so people were
getting into the actual result let me
just first get into the notation of
neural networks to make sure we are on
the same page so for simplicity we will
only consider folly connected networks
for this talk and we think of the
weights we use Sita to represent all the
parameters of the neural network which
in the simple setting is just going to
be all the weight matrices and network
is going to have non-linearity Sigma and
for farthest out just think of Sigma as
standard so we have samples x and y and
we are hoping to learn the networks that
map's X to Y the network just works as
normal so the function computed by the
network f of theta applied to X is just
recursively multiplying with some eight
weight matrix and apply the
non-linearity one thing that's important
here is that the last layer is not
followed by a non-linearity right so the
output is a linear function in the
previous layer so the objective our of
theta is defined as empirical loss so
all of these phenomenons that I talked
about the mode connectivity they are
with respect to the empirical loss so in
practice people did find that if you
just try to connect two random solutions
the test arrow Alonza pass is also good
but but that's even more mysterious okay
so that's why I'm defining the objective
here as empirical loss and here is this
L it's just any convex loss function
it's just a small function L is convex
of course the whole objective is not
convex so think of L as just some
standard losses such as T squares were
across the intro P okay so that's the
neural network that we are going to
consider so first about the lower bound
so what we are able to show is even in a
very simple setting not all local or
global minimum are connected so the
simple setting is that we just have a 2
there in your own network so it's just
input/output and one hidden layer the
question what do you mean by connected
so do you mean that the a and B have the
same objective value and the entire path
at the same value or when you have two
local minima with different value what
do you mean by connect that's right so
in this so in this talk we are going to
yo so by connected I mean if you have
two solutions a and B and if they have
the same objective values then the path
needs to have lower objective values and
both or we can relax that to say you can
have slightly higher objective but not
much higher than both if they have
different objective value then anything
in the past just needs to be less or
equal to them it's a larger one of the
two more
all right well so in this lower bound
without actually the local men that we
talk about we'll have zero loss so they
are all global minimum okay so so the
setting is simple because we are we are
going to have data sets that are
generated by a ground truth neural
network and the ground truth neural
network is actually very small it just
have two hidden neurons and we are going
to consider our parent relation so we
consider the optimization of a two layer
neural network with H hidden neurons and
H can potentially be much much larger
compared to two so what we are able to
prove there is where any H there exists
a data set with h plus two samples such
that the set of global minimizer's are
not connected so there exist two global
minimizer's that if you want to go from
one to the other you will have to leave
the place where like you will have a
point that hat does not have to your
loss so what's important here and the
reason that why that's not contradicting
with the previous result is we have h
plus two samples on h neural network so
this is not in memory or parametrize
regime it's a number of samples training
samples is larger than the number of
neurons
this is still and I mean practice you
would still causes or prom tries because
this network has older H neurons let's
say a 5 H wear constant times H euros
and that's actually larger than the
sorry constant times H parameters and
the number of parameters is definitely
larger than the number of
well here well I'm actually considering
even a least-squares loss so yeah a
regression kind of problem but the
result I can actually be generalized so
one example would be like some
permutation symmetry or perimeter is you
just look right so so in this case the
two global minimizer's we consider they
are not permutations of each other so
they are fairly distinct global
minimizer's if you have enough neurons
can't you just literally copy one
minimizer copy the other minimizer and
then interpolate between them by setting
various ways that's a very good question
so yeah I mean if I'm allowed to
increase the width of the network by a
factor of two then I can always connect
things and in fact that's going to be a
key intuition in the proof that I'm
going to show you later but if you are
not all that what this result is saying
if you are not allowed to modify the
architecture right you are not allowed
to make your layers wider then it's not
clear how you can manipulate within the
limited number of neurons to connect six
okay so let's go up so so now that we
know maybe not all of local or global
minimizer's are connected
what kind of them are connected well so
the empirical results are strong but
they are not really saying that all
alcaman are connected right because we
we cannot really find all the local
minimum or all the global minimum of
so the empirical result are only saying
that local minimum want by standard
optimization algorithms such as SGD so
these are known to be connected other
things as it might also be connected but
we we are not sure right so the C's
local minimum have some nice property
what they surely do but unfortunately we
don't have a very clean characterization
of what properties they should satisfy
right so the property of local min
that's found by standard optimization
algorithm is a very interesting problem
is closely connected to the problem of
generalization because if we know all of
them have some special property we
probably can use those properties to
prove that her generalization bounds and
of course this is related to implicit
regularization if we know what
properties say they have that might be
an effect of the implicit regularization
because of these popular optimization
algorithms right and there are many
conjectures I'm not going to be able to
list all of them for examples or
conjectures that local min found in
practice are flat in some sense the
exact definition of flat is not entirely
clear and there are also conjectures
that local minimum found in practice
have large margin as Mateus and Jason
talked about again the exact definition
of margin in the neural network setting
is debatable like which which portion do
you use so there are many conjectures
but for this talk we are actually going
to focus on a simple definition that we
are going to call dropout stability so
what is dropout stability so we say a
network is epsilon dropout stable if
they're running out 50% goes at every
layer and of course you are allowed to
rescale the output of other neurons that
are remaining so if doing these kind of
things increases its loss by at most
Epsilon
so just in picture this is a say three
layer neural network the dropout version
will look like this of course
in general you don't necessarily want to
drop out also right half of the neurons
but we are just going to premiere things
to that so
so of course drop out stability is
related to drop out training so you if
you are doing drop out training you
would zero out a random 50% fraction but
what we are actually assuming here is a
different version of that we are we only
require you we only require there exists
50% of neurons and when you zero out
those neurons the loss of the neural
network does not increase by too much so
in some sense this is a weaker
requirement than robustness to drop all
training because we only require an
existential result this is the 50%
potentially and of only example being
fed through sorry 50% is the 50%
independent of the example this is just
saying on the training set so this is
talking about loss and the last here is
empirical on 50% is over the entire
training so they ate the same you drop
out and you remove the same 50% of the
notes throughout the entire training set
and for technical reasons we actually
not only require these two networks have
lower loss we also require if you drop
out only it's a top layer were like
consecutive feeds of top few layers and
also has low loss okay so we're going to
be able to prove is if both sets of
parameters are absolute dropout stable
then we can show that there exists a
task between them the maximum loss on
any point of the pass is upper bounded
by the maximum loss of the two endpoints
plus epsilon where epsilon is absolutely
in to a draw stability property so the
proof of this room is actually very
simple so I'm going to be able to show
you
almost the entire proof so so to do that
let me first give you some high-level
intuition of how are we doing trying to
connect things so here I have two
networks right so so these different
patterns represent they have different
weights so the eye level intuition is in
order to connect them I will first
connect the first network to its drop
operation
similarly I will also connect the second
Network which is from operation so now
the good thing is both networks now only
have half of the capacity as before so
actually I can put these two networks
side-by-side like this okay so in this
case I'm putting these two networks
side-by-side so there's no cross
connections between the two networks
those outputs here are exactly is the
same as output for both of the previous
for these two networks so as long as I
do a linear combination of these two
outputs I'm still going to be producing
good output and that is why convexity
after our objective function with
respect to the output of the neural
network so so these two smaller Network
that only half half of the neurons is
very easy to connect them so the really
hard step whereas a harder step is how
do we connect a neural network which is
dropout version so of course the person
I attempt is maybe we can try to do a
direct interpolation direct
interpolation usually doesn't work in
general
so let's even look at a simple case
where you have a two layer linear
network even in that case a direct
interpolation in many cases that's not
work so if the first network is has
parameters u 1 W 1 the second network
has parameters u 2 and if we try to
interpolate between these parameters
with coefficient alpha and 1 minus alpha
what happens is the final functions that
we compute is going to look like
so it has these three terms so the first
term is going to be exactly the matrix
that you are computing for the first set
of parameters so the last term it's
going to be the matrix that you are
computing using the second set of
parameters but unfortunately there's
also this intermediate term which as you
can see has u 1 transpose W 2 and u 2
transpose W 1 so it's a mixture of the
two networks so as Sanjeev said this
remanent is reminiscent of a synth war
which is half human half horse so in
general I mean we don't know what our is
a properties of these Center like terms
if u and W are just fairly arbitrary
then they are not going to do anything
about good right so in general this will
have high cost I have a star here
because it's with stronger assumptions
it is actually possible to do direct
interpolation between a network and
let's drop off version it's just not
possible to do direct interpolation
between
a network and then as are totally
unrelated network so without a stronger
assumption we cannot do direct
interpolation so how can we connect a
network this is operation so here's this
main observation so we are going to use
several line segments to try to connect
them and use two types of line segments
okay so we will say it's a type a
segment if the two endpoints Sita a and
Sita B both have low loss and they only
differ in top layer weight okay so also
preview of the previous layers have the
same weight is only the top layers that
are different in this case we can
linearly interpolate between them
because the last function is actually
convex in the top layer wait so in a
type B line segment it's going to be
well of course just having type 8
segments it's not going to be enough
because we can only change the top layer
weights right in order to change other
layer weights we rely on this type
we move which says if a group of neurons
does not have any outgoing edges right
they are they do not have any outgoing
connections then we can change their
incoming edges arbitrarily because
anyway they are not doing anything right
so changing their incoming edges does
not change itself so the main idea is we
are going to recurse from the top layer
we are going to alternate between these
type A and type B moves and height B
moves are going to prepare us for the
next type a move so here's actually a
pass for a 3 layer Network don't
actually look at the pass I will go
through the pass step-by-step what's
important in this slide is actually for
these three weight matrices this is a
stub you squeeze it out there wait this
is a view to the middle they are made
and this is the bottom they are made
we're going to factorize a word not
characterized but we are going to
partition these weight matrices
according to half of the rows and half
of the columns and this mostly
correspond to the first half of the
neurons and the second half of the
neurons in the two hidden layers and in
this case we are always assuming that we
are dropping out the right half of the
neurons
okay so let's actually look at this pass
so here's the first step the first step
is quite simple so I have this neural
network I'm going to change the top
layer weight to 2 L 3 0 so I only keep
the left part of the weight and I
multiply the weight by a factor of 2 to
compensate so obviously in this case
only the top layer weight changes and
the two endpoints are both good by the
drop a stable assumption so the first
step is simple so so in the second step
we are not going to do a type B move
because now if you look at this
right-hand side of the top hidden layer
it no longer has any outgoing edges so I
can change this incoming edges
arbitrarily and I change that to 2 times
l2 so these neurons are now going to be
connected to
first half of the neurons in the next
layer word just to illustrate it more
clearly these ways and the way the
incoming edges for these guys and these
guys are are totally unrelated parts of
the matrix so you can think that the
network now has these two separate
components one that's giving the current
output one that's preparing for the next
step okay so the next step is going to
be that we flip the top layer weights
from the left-hand side to the
right-hand side okay so why is this okay
this is okay because one we are only
changing the top layer weight and two of
the two endpoints are going to be both
good obviously the first endpoint is
good it was the last point of the
previous step so the reason that the
second endpoint is good is because it's
actually equivalent to this neural
network who is wait two hours three
times - ow - so basically it so this is
equivalent to a dropout version we are
be dropout both of the right parts okay
so so that's the third step actually if
you are just doing a straight layer from
here you can do some further clean-up
and the pass is going to be complete I'm
going to show you more steps as those
are required for the induction if you
want to go to more layers so the next
step is going to be okay so now instead
of the right part has no connection now
the left part does not have any outgoing
edges so I can change the incoming edges
of the left part arbitrarily and I
changed that to the same thing two times
l2 so so it's now only connected to the
left part of the first hidden layer and
obviously this didn't change the output
so it's okay so second to last step I
again switch back from a switch from the
right part to the left part in this case
the two endpoints are actually
corresponding to the same network so so
nothing is changing in
is a set so this is already the second
to last step as you can see after this
step the right part of the top hidden
layer has no outgoing edges the right
part of the first hidden layer does not
have any upcoming edges so I can freely
change all the incoming edges for both
of them the next step I'm going to set
all of them to zero so this green part
basically disappears from the network
this green part also disappears from the
network and we get this final drop out
version of the network so just by doing
these steps we have connected a three
layer neural network to its drop out
version and in every step we are
guaranteed that the loss is bounded by
the maximum loss of its two endpoints
all the endpoints have bounded loss
because of dropout stability so that's
how we can do the connection it's fairly
straightforward to actually extend this
kind of construction to multiple layers
you just need to do so so final result
in the paper that I'm just going to very
briefly mention is we can replace
drop-off stability with Roy stability so
at a very high level we say a network is
noise stable if the injecting noise and
intermediate layers does not change the
output by too much so the precise
definition is a bit messy and it was
similar to the definitions that we used
before in this paper which was aiming to
prove better generalization bounds for
neural networks so using the stronger
assumption we are going to be able to
show if both parameters are Epsilon
noise stable since there is a pass with
a similar guarantee as before what
slightly stronger here is we can prove
that the past consists of exactly ten
line segments so a constant number of
line segments it's possible to improve
this number ten but we also don't have
any idea how to improve from ten to two
so so we didn't bother to exact doing
that
and in contrast the previous
construction is going to have number of
line segments that's proportional to the
number of layers the main idea here is
that noise stability under this
definition actually implies tripod
stability and further it actually
implies something stronger if you have
noise turbidity you can do direct
interpolation so here are some
experimental results so these are passed
constructed according to the drop out
version of the theorem so the so this is
a smaller data set amnesty and also a
smaller neural network as you can see
for amnesty the serum works very well
throughout the pass the loss is very low
the accuracy remains high the theory is
that have definitely not perfect on CFR
10 we are looking at a much larger and
your network with GG 11 and in this case
we used to drop our training but even in
that case we cannot construct a very
ideal pass as you can see the loss does
increase in the middle and accuracy
decreases question x axis is just a path
a path parameter T so sync off when T is
zero is one endpoint when T is one is
another endpoint and when T is in
between is all the points on lawns are
constructed the path basically using the
proof that I showed the Orcas now yes
that's pretty much what I wanted a stick
so this is the path that you construct
your poop so how do you find those 50
percents in this Oh in in this uh in
this if at an example we just randomly
throw away half of this okay well well I
mean we tried to do this repeatedly and
picks a better one but they are actually
fairly well concentrated we might be
able to do better by in pruning these
neurons more carefully but we haven't so
that's basically so I believe this was
actually just well in some sense the
past parameter T just doesn't say
anything because the past parameter T
like you can always scale the parameter
T so I think in this case so I'm
actually not exactly sure I think in
this case this middle part is when we
when we go to the drop out on the first
few layers so the main problem in the
experiment is when we apply to drop out
to the early layers of the neural
network the accuracies
so I imagine the original papers I
forget the exact details but imaginary
deliveries showing mode connectivity did
not use this drop out approach because
spinning this right so the simplest way
to actually find these passing practice
is you just parameterize the middle
point the a to B to C the OSR 8o c to b
you parameterize the middle point and
you'll optimize a loss function yes I
guess what I'm wondering about is have
you gone back in like books a these are
the paths that you find the the previous
like high-tech approaches are they
somehow qualitatively similar to what
you they are qualitatively better it is
in the three part case in the amnesties
I mean they are all kind of similar but
in the C part in case the past there is
actually have lower loss in what it's
just two intervals yes yeah so it's a
definite arrastia gasps promises past
worse since the past that's actually far
you know what just the convex line
segment right that's something that we
should try but we haven't done that
actually but if you actually I don't
want to go back but if you go back to
the first slide you can see that that's
actually an experiment on CFR 10 and the
direct interpolation has a loss of 5 or
something so this is Stephanie's do
better than that but we should probably
show a comparison but but the past it's
not ideal good so they say you are are
zero on half of the neurons they don't
have to be at the matching like it's not
that one neuron that you zero out and
one has to be not zero not in the others
they don't have to be a line in the
actual proof we have more steps to say
how do you promote things so that one of
them is going to zero out only half of
the right half and one of them is only
going to offer that and so I didn't talk
about that stuff okay so the mean you
try to wrap up so a short conclusion for
neural networks
maybe not all local or global mean are
connected but we can show that some of
them are connected especially those
satisfied rawat stability so there are
many open problems here so there are
obvious ones that we have already
discussed of course passeth found by
these techniques of our serums are still
more complicated than the fast pound in
practice and passed known are known to
exist in practice even if the solutions
are not as drop out stable as we wanted
but the most surprised are the most
interesting open problem to me is can we
leverage this mod connectivity property
to design better optimization algorithms
right so why is this related to
optimization well if you think about it
if all local minimum are connected than
all the level sets of the problem so
level sets are just set up points that
are below a certain objective value so
all of the level sets are also connected
you cannot have this kind of function
you have to have at this straight line
here so even if you only have to be her
version even if only all the typical
solutions are connected and there is a
typical global minimum then it in some
sense local search algorithm will not be
completely stuck in the sense that even
if you are actually stuck there is
actually a path from your point to the
global minimizer's that's not increasing
in objective function value so it seems
to say that optimization is good but of
course not quite because there can still
be flat regions or high order saddle
points that we don't know how to deal
with so can we have better optimization
algorithm where may be optimization like
gradient descent it's not working can we
have some sampling algorithm like I
launched a bit more to follow so it can
leverage these kind of properties better
right so with that I think it's a very
interesting open problem so that's all
sense
[Applause]
sorry so I I mean for empirically for
neural networks if you will find the
local minimizer's using the standard
optimization algorithms then you can use
a different algorithm to find a path
between these two these local
minimizer's such that actually entire
loss on the passes is below a war is not
much higher than the two endpoints yeah
but what what we show here is under some
assumptions we can prove that in the
first slide in protocol results those
are just two random initializations or
mics remnants they are also just two
I guess we are many Oliver dicks oh I
guess there's no thanks speak okay
[Applause]